عرضه ستاند اب كوميدي للفنانه الامريكيه
كفن هارت في القاهره يثير موجه من الغضب
في مصر فبمجرد ان اعلن عن العرض الذي من
المقرر ان يعقد في القاهره في 21 من
فبراير القادم انطلقت في مصر حملات على
مواقع التواصل اجتماعي تطالب بالغاء
ومقاطعه الحفل عبر وسم الغاء حفلت فيما لم
يذكر اي رد فعل رسمي من كبنهاورت حول
الحمله التي تنتقده
[موسيقى]
انه لما كافر هارت يجي مصر يعني ويتكلم في
الحفله بتاعته بيقول الهرم بتاعنا الناس
هتقول له ايه
الموضوع اللي يلقب حاجه حصل تقريبا من
حوالي سنه فكان في المؤتمر اللي كان
هيتعمل بتاع الافروسان تريزم ودي حركه
بيتمناها سليبرتس كتير جدا في امريكا
او من اكثر الناس
منهمز بريك
بيونسي ناس كثيره قوي انه باختصار شديد
الحضاره المصريه الفراعنه كانوا اا من
اصحاب البشره السمراء هما
افرقه
ولما
حصل احتلال عربي اتهجروا ليه وسط وجنوب
القاره
وان الحضاره المصريه دي عملها اصحاب
البشره السمراء يعني لا في كان اميريكانز
فدول دول اجدادهم اللي عملوا الحضاره
وبينوا الاهرامات وان احنا المصريين اللي
عايشين دلوقتي واجداد واجداد اجدادنا دول
نجوم احتلوا مصر
[موسيقى]
المركزيه الافريقيه التي تاتي على فكره
الانسانيه الكبرى نشات من الثقافه
الافريقيه وان اصل الانسان من حيث
وجدت البشريه واستوطنات كانت في افريقيا
بالتالي ان مصر القديمه كانت ارضا للسود
للمصريين القدامى ما رايك
هي طبعا حركه
المنظمه يعني عنصريه بغيضه نشات في امريكا
والغرب وبعد الدول الاوروبيه
بيدعمها
يعني اهلها اللي هو من اصول افريقيه اييه
طبعا هي ظهرت في مواجهه الغرب والحضاره
الغربيه البيضاء فلازم يرجعوا او يشوفوا
حاجه قويه تقدر تصمت قدام حضاره الغرب او
تبقى لها بذور ما لقوش الا الحضاره
المصريه القديمه
استندوا في كده لبعض التماثيل المصريه
القديمه اللي كانت بتلون باللون الاسود
وقالوا ان ال- ال- الفراعنه كانوا افارقه
من السود ودي نظريه طبعا مغلوطه الا ان هم
لو قروا التاريخ يعني يعرفوا ان اللون
الاسود ده له رمزيه عند المصري القديم
وكان بيرمز له ازوريس اله العالم الاخر
البنات ما بيرموش ابدا للون الشخص مش معنى
ده الظهر باللون الاسود ان هو دكتور دكتور
هندي
رقم هذا الجدل الاكثر فاكثر يعني هل تسميه
المصريين القدامى بالفراعنه ومساله
الحضاره الفرعونيه هو الخطا الشائع الذي
يثير جدل لانه دائما هناك تركيز انه لا
تقول الفراعنه قولوا المصريين القدامى هل
هذا خلق ايضا جدل ما هي الفراعنه هو كلمه
فرعون بتطلق بتطلق على الحاكم فهي يعني
يعني الناس بقى يقولوا ايه الفراعنه همم
مصطلح على المصريين القدماء بصفه عامه بس
احنا كمصريين احنا مصريين بنرجع وبنتسب
الى المصريين القدماء لكن رقم فرعون ده
كان بيطلق على الحاكم الحاكم المصري مش كل
المصريين كانوا بيلقبوا بلقب فرعون
فالدكتوره هند ما بتشعر انه في شويه نوع
من العنصريه مثلا يعني لما يكون في حاله
انكار شديده انه لا لا يعني مصر اللم تكون
ارضا للسود
لا لا احنا ما بنقولش كده ازاي يعني بص
حضرتك لا احنا ما بنقولش كده بس هو دي
مغلطه تاريخيه لما هم يجوا ينصبوا حضارتنا
ليهم لا ده ده بتغلط في التاريخ بقى
عاوز تنفي هوياتنا وتثبت لنفسك هويه من لا
شيء ما ينفعش ولازم لان لازم احنا نقف
ونتصدى لدعاوى زي كده انا يعني الافر
والسنترول كانت هتعمل مؤتمر برده في في
برايل الماضي وتلغى كان في اسوان كان اسمه
العوده للجذور افريقيا الموحده والعوده
للجذور طب الجذور مين وعوده لفين يعني
كانوا عايزين يخرجوا بتوصيات ان هم يرجعوا
تاني لمصر وان دي ارضهم
دي ما فيش الكلام ده
[موسيقى]